as the proud daughter of your nominee I
am here to tell you that this is the
moment and Donald Trump is the person to
make America great again Ivanka Trump
wowed the crowd at the Republican
National Convention and some suggest
that she's her dad's greatest campaign
asset he's been an exceptional father to
me he's been an exceptional leader but
Ivanka tells Harper's Bazaar she's a
hardly running Donald's campaign quote
his campaign is his campaign
my role is daughter still what about a
political run of her own someday
not so fast quote no it's not something
I think I would ever do 34 year olds
also dishes on her friendship with
Chelsea Clinton saying the political
battle between her dad and Hillary
Clinton isn't affecting their
relationship quote I'm not running for
public office and neither is she so of
course we're still friends
Chelsea echoed that sentiment to et just
days ago our friendship didn't start
with politics and it will last long
after this race is is done it